[Music]
let's go to liz in oceanside california
what's up liz
hey john how are you
so good how about you i'm doing great
good i just uh i was just wanted to get
your feedback about
well i'm a stay-at-home mom i have two
kids one's two and one's eight months
old oh gosh can i just make the
i don't know some special sign for you
is it how are we doing are you doing all
right
yeah i uh currently i got like four
hours of sleep last night i think it's a
conspiracy between
uh my husband and my two kids but um you
know
when's the last time i just asked the
last caller this when's the last time
you just casually got up from wherever
you were and just went to the bathroom
by yourself
surprisingly that's going okay still i'm
i think my two-year-old
i think my two-year-old is an
independent player enough that um i can
actually get away with that sometimes
but we'll see how long that lasts
that's so cool all right it's the little
things it's a little i remember the
first time this is
me just being i'm half ashamed and
vulnerable my
uh my kids were gone
and
i mean my wife was gone and my son was
like one and i had to go to the bathroom
and i remember getting up to go and then
stopping and just looking being like
oh
oh he wasn't one he was just a few
months old and i was like oh i guess
you're i guess i guess you're coming in
i guess you're just gonna stare at me
right and yeah that's like seared into
my soul every time i see him even though
he's like 11 now i think do you remember
that it was super weird anyway that's
cool all right so what's up liz sorry
yeah now you're fighting
um yeah i just wanted to get your
feedback about
how to use my iphone around my kids in a
way
that is positive for our relationship
and for their development and
i just felt a little lost on this issue
because it really wasn't something that
my parents had a chance to model for me
because it wasn't an issue didn't exist
yeah hey what an awesome question
especially what an awesome question for
with young kids like let's plan what
this thing's gonna look like downstream
that's so great good for you
um all right so here uh
here's the thing we don't have a ton
it may exist i haven't seen it i don't
haven't seen a ton of
hard research on this it's so still so
new what we're gonna find out 20 years
from now or 15 years from now
um is what happened we're playing a
giant social experiment
where we handed every parent in the
world a giant distraction and then said
go raise kids and we'll see what happens
exactly that scares me
me too
i will tell you that um
when i think back over the last decade i
literally can melt my own heart with how
i've handled this i have not done it
well
and it's only been in the last couple
years that i've even gotten hyper
intentional about it and then the last
year or two since i've been telling
everybody about it every day that i've
gotten pathological about it
so here's a couple of my rules and if
you can this is just for me these aren't
rules for everybody else everybody's
life is different and i'll also say when
i was on call 24 7 365 there was a
reality to that
i had to have my phone around because i
may have to go to a hospital and i don't
have that anymore so i know that there's
everybody's different so here's a couple
of big rules
if i'm on my phone communicating if i'm
texting somebody if i'm trying to answer
an email real quick and i'm just in
passing
and one of my kids comes in
i call it out
so i say loudly hey let me finish this
i'm sending a message
if it's appropriate i tell him who i'm
sending a work message i'm sending a
message to one of my friends i'm sending
a message to your mom hang on
and what i'm doing when that happens is
i'm acknowledging a human just walked
into the room and
more importantly it's one of the most
important humans on planet earth to me
i'm not ignoring you
one of the biggest challenges for kids
is they want to be seen they have to be
seen that's a part of their physiology
part of their biology right and so they
walk into a room and they feel like a
ghost they will begin
doing things to be seen and so i want to
make sure i see you and i need to finish
this thing because they may not be the
most important thing in my moment right
in that in that second but they are the
most important person so the second
thing is
when ever possible
i do not have that box in my hand when
my kids are in my presence
that's just become a thing for me i
watch them toggle between my eyes and
the phone and my eyes and the phone in
my eyes on the phone
and i don't like that
there's i don't i don't have a
double-blind study
but there's something not natural about
that they are checking
in real time
who am i looking at what's important to
dad
and they have to know they're important
um i do if i have to i've got to send a
couple of emails i got to respond to
this text messages my friend's having a
challenge i got to get in the middle of
it
i do i'll go in my room and shut the
door
and then that way i can be fully present
with this phone and i can put the phone
down and then i can go back out
i will also say i failed this regularly
liz i kind of suck at it sure
and it's i i get frustrated with myself
like i'll think to myself my kids are
right out there playing and i'm here
scrolling on some stupid thing
so um i i have to remind myself to put
this thing down it is it's a drug for me
and um i've got to be careful about it
the other thing is i think it's
important not to demonize the phone i
think the thing we need to be it's just
a tool it's just it's a hammer it's a
screwdriver so
um
i quit talking bad about it
i i used to tell my son you know there's
that old homer simpson quote that i love
which is the best part about having kids
is to teach them to hate the things that
you hate that was funny until the last
four or five years then it just hasn't
been so funny anymore um but i
don't want them to think the phone is
evil it's just a it's a tool i want them
to
watch self-control and watch where my
attention is and so
um if it's out it's out
right that's what i say every time i
don't let my my son uh my my son is my
two-year-old i don't ever let him just
hold my phone or play with my phone
right yes
and so i um i always tell him if he gets
it like hey mommy's phone is not a it's
not a toy it's a tool yes and so and
it's for adults it's for adults right
and so as we get older like i'll tell my
kids hey that that's an adult movie this
is
you know i got to watch the new chapelle
special this is a this is an adult show
this is not for kids and this is adult
talk time this is when me and your mom
are talking y'all go play um my kids
understand that language that adults
have conversations that are not for them
that they're not included in
and so this goes into that bucket and
this is an adult tool same as when we're
hunting and i've got gun like those i
handle those right and so it just
becomes one of those things it's just
something to be aware of
um
what are you worried about when it comes
to how you handle this stuff
yeah i'm just uh really worried about
messing this up
um no i i have that same gut instinct i
guess that that's been creeping up more
and more um
as my two-year-old especially is getting
you know more more and more aware
i'm afraid that he is going to feel
um like i'm not present like i'm
even your show has been a problem john
i've had to turn off your show and be
because i could tell there's like a
podcast running in the background
even if i'm just not holding my phone he
knows that my mental space is somewhere
else yes
so i've had to limit like okay maybe i
should just listen to one one podcast in
the morning or or not at all
until his nap time or something but i'm
gonna stop you right there this show's
way more important than any kid you i
don't know what
way more important than your children
um okay so you know what you're
describing i've never heard it described
this way but you just did it perfectly
let's say you have a parent with an
alcohol addiction or an opioid addiction
and they're sitting on the couch
and a kid sees them
hears them
and can touch them
but a kid can feel they are com in
another place
right and it becomes like a numbing
mechanism almost i think it exactly and
the kids will solve for they will try to
make that leap to that connection with
their parent for the rest of their life
and if you're holding a phone it's the
same they see you they hear you
they can touch your leg
but you're gone you're not there and so
yeah your instinct is so right
i think the cool thing we can all do we
can all work on this
is
coming up with some practices
do the phone go in the drawer are there
times when i'm gonna check my phone and
this is hard for a stay-at-home mom
because now you're talking about
disconnecting yourself from the rest of
the world right
right and it's it's lonely it's true
yeah it's it can be
like i just found myself listening to
podcasts a ton because i love learning
and i love growing in knowledge and how
to be a good parent
and and all these good things and
there's so many good things to listen to
but can i tell you can i tell you the
one insidious thing
yeah here's the one insidious thing
it's learning and growing is cool
but
podcast voices of which i am one
bypasses all of your other senses
so up until
75 years ago
if you were communicating with somebody
you saw them they're in your presence
they might even be on a stage far away
but they were with you
and just 75 years ago when we came up
with the radio or maybe it was 100 years
ago i don't remember
we started bypassing that and our brains
are dealing with something that they are
not designed to deal with which is
somebody's voice pipe directly into
their into your brain
and why am i telling you this it is cool
to learn it is cool to get connected
it's cool to figure things out it's cool
to learn new tools and things but you're
also getting a cheap substitute for
connection
there's parts of your brain and body
that you and i are friends and we've
never even met right
um absolutely there are times i found
myself in the past reaching out to a
podcast just cause i missed a voice you
know what i mean i missed the inside
jokes and i should be having those with
real people which is hard for a mom
who's staying at home with two little
ones two two years and younger
so here's the here's what i want you to
focus on focus on where and when am i
fully present if i'm going to be on the
phone with my friends i want to be fully
on the phone with my friends
totally
if i'm going to respond to texts
and emails and get the hilarious memes
and ask the questions about like
what does this rash look like i want to
be fully in that conversation and when
i'm not fully there i want to be fully
with my kids and if i'm not fully with
my kids i want to be fully in the book
or in the podcast i'm listening to not
doing 10 things at once because you know
we all know now that um
that toggling back and forth
multitasking is a myth it's not real
it's just your brain going back and back
and back and back and back back and
forth
and so where can you are so present
does that make sense
yes so
i think maybe let's do this and i'm i'm
thinking this out loud with you because
i'm a parent who struggles with this too
maybe instead of wondering what we do
with the phone which is real i'm not
going to get my kids phones even my
middle schoolers come back and said man
i really thank you
i'm not going to get my kids phones
that's all simple i'm going to continue
to work on
being connected with my kid making sure
they see that i see them
but beneath that let's forget the phone
when i'm where i'm at i want to be fully
present wherever i'm at
when i'm when as soon as i get on a
plane to go speak somewhere i'm going to
be fully there because missing like miss
my kids
that doesn't help me see them that
doesn't help me honor the people i'm
going to speak to it just makes me feel
bad so i'm going to be all in i'm going
to be when i go to new city i'm going to
enjoy myself there i'm going to enjoy it
when i'm back at home i'm going to be
fully at home does that make sense
yep i'm talking to my friends let's be
there so you give me i'm gonna let you
turn the tables you give me a practice
that i'm gonna agree to do
when it comes to having two little kids
in the house and phones you tell me and
i'll be all in
okay let's see
well i thought of this
a couple days ago i was thinking maybe
if i kept my drawer i kept my phone
in my bedroom drawer and turned all the
way up so i can hear it it's you know
something my husband calls or something
and i really need to get it
um
but just sort of keeping it in there and
not having it readily accessible
around me just for the morning until
until nap time
so what time is dab time
that time is the one it's at one after
lunch
okay if you can make it till noon
man that's some willpower
you're not even a real adult
all right so here's the deal here's
here's the thing i'm in i'm in so i'm
going to
i've got my social media on my work
phones that's on one other thing
my commitment for the next 30 days is
that phone does not leave my truck
when i get home it stays in the car and
then i will see it again the next day
and so i won't mess with it in the
morning that's my commitment for 30 days
cool
cool second thing is my phone will go in
a drawer
hey that's so dumb for me my
self-service doesn't even work it's such
a [ __ ] that i carry it around
my phone is going to go in a drawer
and i will check it at intervals
throughout the afternoon or evening and
i will not pick it up check it before i
go to work that way i can be fully
present with myself fully present with
my morning routine my spiritual stuff
and with my family amen you in
i'm in okay promise me that you will not
go off on an island though you need
other people that means you may have to
invite people over
yeah okay
you may have to be weird and invite
friends over i don't know if that's
legal in california but you got it
yeah good so set up a couple of mornings
a week tell someone to bring their weird
little kid over and y'all can just stare
at each other no cleaning up no makeup
no nothing
you bring whatever coffee you got left
and i'll i got a banana and a half left
and let's just hang out
is that cool
yeah that sounds good oh my gosh liz we
are changing the world
goodly oh you just made me happy all
right challenge accepted to everyone
listening phone's in the drawer no
social media before work let's try that
for 30 days and see what happens here's
what's gonna happen you're gonna sleep
better your life's gonna be better
you're gonna have better sex with your
spouse your kids are gonna like you and
all that kind of stuff but let's pretend
we don't know what's gonna happen and
let's go from there